[Musique]
samedi emmanuel macron tenait sa
cérémonie d'investiture en direct de
l'elysée chaque jour du mandat qui
s'ouvre je n'aurais qu'une boussole
servir parmi les invités plusieurs
proches du président dont nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande mais aussi
bernard montiel
une présence qui a amusé in partisans du
rassemblement national marie émilie
euphrasie le dernier épisode de vidéo
gag bernard montiel dans le carré
culture à l'investiture des manuels
macron mais cette moquerie n'a pas été
du goût de bernard montiel qui a répondu
à ces provocations par un truc qui l'a
ensuite supprimé quelques audaces la
fachos et méprisante à étonnants je
n'étais pas dans le carré culture et je
vous emmerde avec plaisir le porte
parole du rassemblement national julien
odoul alors voler à la rescousse de sa
militante en attaquant à son tour
bernard montiel m bernard montiel dans
le kerry culture c'est comme exposé un
rouleau de pq dans la galerie des glaces
du château de versailles soutient marie
émilie euphrasie insulté par ce pauvre
type beaucoup trop payé ce soir julien
houle s'explique face à bernard montiel
bravo bravo à tous les deux alors merci
généraux do not la sicile on va parler
de berne a remonté la voilà qui s'est
lâché sur les réseaux sociaux où il a
pété un câble et celles à frire fois
bref je sais pas c'est pas la dernière
alors samedi donc bernard montiel était
à la cérémonie d'investiture des manuels
macron il est passé sur toutes les
chaînes après problème c'est que
personne ne savait ce qu'il foutait là
regardez
nos deux ministres qui sont
effectivement franck riester qui est
juste à côté de moi vous voyez bernard
montiel qui est là qui êtes invité e un
certain nombre de députés juste derrière
bernard montiel donc c'est le coin une
culture je confirme
mais de ça alors là c'est tombé
inculture là on allègue que mélissa vous
avez gallienne jean marc dumontet
criteria conducteur très prochainement
c'est bernard montiel qui appartient
donc
bernard montiel qui
n'avait pas vu ça j'adore quand on voit
que tu viola a été très bon
c'est passé c'est génial j'avais pas vu
ça c'est une énorme d'arc a chaviré
après dans quel coin j'étais c'était
alors qu'ils étaient présents bien
qu'ils avaient françois cluzet il y
avait des dirigeants normal jacques
attali guillaume gallienne il y avait
françois cluzet il avait déjà devenir
viens de le dire sénat alors ce qu avant
son discours emmanuel macron
officiellement été investi par laurent
fabius président du conseil
constitutionnel constitutionnel mais le
mec a complètement pété l'ambiance
regarde et cetera sera d'amener le temps
de votre premier mandat
a été notamment percuté par une
accumulation
grise et de bouleversements sur le plan
sanitaire
sécuritaire sociale énergétique
financiers dont les conséquences ne sont
pas toutes terminées avec un certain
malaise démocratique
[Applaudissements]
tu prend dans la gueule
c'est du roi alors pendant le discours
du président il y avait 450 un miteux
qui était bien sûr très consciente et il
y avait bernard montiel il écouté très
attentivement et c'est simple au fond je
crois qu'ils sont tous amoureux des
manuels macro regarde le peuple français
n'a pas prolongé le mandat qui s'achève
commencé le 14 mai 2017 ce peuple
nouveau différent d'il ya cinq ans a
confié un président nouveau un mandat
nouveau
[Musique]
en somme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un journaliste de france 2 a fait une
interview dans la voiture de françois
bayrou iain cadart c'est la façon dont
se retourne françois bayrou on regarde
et lui offrira aux côtés de l'un des
invités effectivement important un
fidèle de la majorité c'est françois
bayrou damas oui exactement nous sommes
en route bonjour françois bayrou
vous êtes un très proche des manuels
macron
le gars le gagnant de trois de
leurs voix aux
côtés de l'un des invités effectivement
important un fidèle de la majorité c'est
françois bayrou thomas oui exactement
nous sommes en route bonjour françois
bayrou
vous êtes un très proche des manuels
macron
qui a énormément fait parler cedao
accolade entre emmanuel macron edouard
philippe le premier ministre du début de
son quinquennat et ça se voit que les
deux et en embrouille ces derniers temps
parce que c'est la plus longue poignée
de main de l'histoire des poignées de
mains nues regardez la sauce autour
passer un live le coc vie de l'eau
typhus
et puis on est aussi en plein dans la
lah fort le gars gironde et du coup face
aux aléas économiques et dwyer laurent
fabius a rappelé les droits et les
devoirs du sable
donc c'est vraiment un discours royal je
crois qu'il est bon je crois qu'il a
quand même rendu un vrai hommage à la
nation française
[Musique]
c'est secondes plus tard françois bayrou
je vous cache pas que l'option petit
retourné nous inspirer regarde oui oui
exactement nous sommes en route bonjour
françois bailly louche
[Applaudissements]
oui exactement nous sommes en route
bonjour françois bayrou y a
[Musique]
exactement nous sommes en route bonjour
françois bayrou guignols
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
sur tf1 cette cérémonie très dépendantes
il avait voulu voir ce que les français
en pensez et apparemment tout le monde
n'était pas à fond sur la cérémonie
regardée quel que soit votre âge quel
que soit votre opinion politique le lieu
où vous habitez l'investiture d'un
président a forcément une signification
pour vous mathieu karman et nos équipes
partout en france vous ont demandé ce
que représentait à vos yeux cette
journée très particulière
enfin cérémonie ou pas c'est important
mais non ça m'intéresse pas trop on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir une cérémonie
d'investiture plus caustique de soissons
il a été élu
la bonne ambiance bonne ambiance